okay let me break it down for you 4,000  soldiers tens of thousands of rounds  fired in a bunch of [ __ ] helicopters  there was no way Pablo Escobar was  getting out of this one right my life  about Pablo Escobar has escaped from  prison yeah it was the biggest law  enforcement blunder of all time and now  me wanted payback an alliance is fun  it's the objective of taking on Escobar  this wasn't a manhunt this was an  invasion what the problem was  Pablo was never more dangerous than when  you almost had him  the followers kuhlmeier send a nice  pizza  those guys are fighting by the same  rules why should we you know what that  means  oh I do  we're another he pays well  from the gallows and I don't have very  long today it's a different kind of  soldier  we need